Okay, good morning. So, today we do
Islam.
Um
some quick facts,
some questions that we will look at
today about uh the Islamic Golden Age.
Uh the first major question is,
while Europe was in its Dark Ages,
uh Islam was embarked on its Golden Age.
So, the first question is,
how this happened? Why was there Where
Why was there here this divergence?
Second question we're going to look at
is,
um what ended the Islamic Golden Age?
Why would this period come to an end?
The third question we're going to look
at is, eventually, how did Christian
Europe overtake the Muslim world?
Um so, those are the three big questions
we will look at in today's class.
Some quick facts about Islam.
It is the world's second largest
religion. Uh Christianity has 2 billion
people. Islam has 1 billion people.
Uh they are divided into two major
sects, the Shia, which is based
primarily in Iran, and the Sunni, uh
which is uh everywhere else. Uh the
light green are the Sunni people, and
the dark green are the Shia people. And
as you can see, uh Islam extends all
across Africa, the Middle East, and
Central Asia, and into India. The most
populous uh Muslim country in the world
is actually Indonesia.
Um
the Shia and the Sunni,
the only the only major difference is
that the Shia believe that only a direct
descendant of Muhammad's grandson, Ali,
can be the leader of the religion,
whereas the Sunni do not believe this.
Now, um this is a religion of 1 billion
people, so there are many different
belief system, many different sects
within this uh cosmology, but um this is
really the major difference, okay?
Between the Shia and the Sunni.
Um so,
Muslim
means to submit yourself to God, to
believe in God, and to submit yourself
wholeheartedly
to him.
And
um
Islam was founded by a man named
Muhammad, who
um the Muslims consider the prophet of
God, the final prophet. And Jesus was
the penultimate prophet.
And um the legend is that
at age 40, uh Muhammad, who who is a
merchant or a trader, he has a vision.
He goes in a cave to meditate, and the
Archangel Gabriel visits him and reveals
to him certain visions that he has
memorized. And these visions become the
basis for the holy book of the Muslim um
tradition called the Quran.
And he and uh Muhammad understands that
his mission is to be a messenger of God,
and to reveal the truth of God to the
big pagan society in the Arabian world.
So, he's based in Mecca. Um and we when
he tries to reveal a truth, he is met
with a lot of resistance. And
eventually, he's forced out of Mecca,
and he goes to uh Medina. Uh this is
called the Hijra in the Muslim
tradition, the pilgrimage.
And when he goes to Medina, um he
becomes the leader of the warring
factions within uh Medina, primarily
between the pagans, the Muslim tribes,
and the Jewish tribes. So, there are
three major factions. And um at this
point, Muhammad creates something called
the Constitution of Medina, which
promises
religious freedom to everyone within the
Muslim tradition.
Okay? So, ever since the beginning, and
this is very important,
the religion of Islam was a open,
tolerant, and inclusive religion. And
they have They have basically maintained
this tradition for the next thousand
years.
Okay?
Um
Eventually, Islam will spread from the
Arabian desert to all across the Middle
East. They will conquer the Persian
Empire, and they will take at least half
of the Byzantine Empire, uh including
the richest parts of the Byzantine
Empire, which are Syria and uh Egypt.
They will also take Jerusalem, where
they will build something called the
Al-Aqsa Mosque. And legend has it
that Muhammad
um ascended to heaven from this place.
Now, what's really important for us to
remember about this place is the Al-Aqsa
Mosque, it's still there in Jerusalem.
And it is
built on top of something called the
Temple Mount.
Remember, in year 70, the Romans burned
down the second temple of the Jews, the
holiest site in the Jewish faith.
And now and then the Muslims came and
built the Al-Aqsa Mosque on top of the
Temple Mount.
Now, this is a very strange thing to do.
If Muslim if the Muslim tradition is
open, inclusive, and tolerant, and Jews
are welcome into the into the into the
tradition, why would you build a mosque
on top of the Jewish holy site? That
doesn't really make any sense. And quite
honestly, this has been a mystery to
everyone. No one has been able to figure
this out, okay? So, we will today
attempt to solve one of the great
mysteries in the Islamic tradition. Why
was the Al-Aqsa Mosque built on top of
the Jewish Temple Mount? Okay?
Um as I mentioned, the
Arabs will expand from the desert of
Arabia, and they will conquer the
Sasanian Persian Empire,
and they will take at least half of the
Byzantines, okay? They will try to lay
siege on Constantinople, but remember
that when we discussed the Byzantine
Empire, Constantinople is designed as an
impenetrable fortress. So, there are
there will be two major sieges,
and because of the walls and because of
Greek fire, um they will be unable to
take the city.
Um the spread of Islam was lightning
fast. In less than 100 years, they
spread from the desert of Arabia, really
the poorest place in this entire region,
throughout most of
uh the Middle East, okay? So, the dark
green is where they started, and the
light green is where they eventually um
expanded to. And remember, this process
takes less than 100 years, which is
remarkable.
Um
The The Umayyad Caliphate was about 700,
okay? So, let's just compare the Umayyad
Caliphate with other empires, including
the Tang. Okay, the Tang really is the
height of Chinese Chinese civilization,
but as you can see, the Umayyad
Caliphate
um really is the largest empire in the
world at this time. And eventually, they
will also become the wealthiest empire
um at this time.
Um there are five pillars of Islam.
It is an extremely
simple and clear religion when compared
with Christianity and Judaism.
Okay, there are five pillars
to the religion. Um first of all, you
have to believe that Allah, God, is the
only God.
Okay? And this mirrors the
Christian and the Jewish faith.
Um you are required to pray at least
five times a day facing the direction of
uh Mecca.
You must give
uh money to the poor.
Um you must fast during the holidays.
The last thing is, you must make
something called the Hajj, uh which is a
pilgrimage to the holy site in Mecca,
and perform rituals in Mecca. This is
something that um all Muslims must do,
and you will have the poorest Muslims,
they will save uh their entire lives
just so that they could make this Hajj.
Okay? The Muslim people are probably the
most devout, uh the most religious
people you will meet. They take their
religion very, very seriously.
This is the Hajj in uh Mecca. And
um I was actually in Saudi Arabia, and I
tried to go there. And I was told, "Only
Muslims can go."
And And And so, I was at at a train
station, I was I was trying to buy a um
ticket to Mecca, and they said, "What's
your Muslim name?" Like, "Well, I'm not
Muslim." They're like, "Well, you can't
go then." So, I was disappointed. Uh
but, it is a beautiful,
um absolutely one of the most beautiful
rituals in the world today.
Okay.
Um so, to summarize the introduction,
there were three major mysteries to the
history of Islam that we still haven't
really solved today.
Okay, the first mystery is
Um, we know that they have something
called the constitution constitution of
Medina. We also know that Jews who are
literate were part of the early movement
of Islam. So, why do we have we have no
early records for the first 100 years?
What the first 100 years of the
movement? That's very very strange.
Okay? Um, another strange
question another strange
um
thing is why would the Muslims go to war
against two major empires?
The Romans and the Persians.
That's kind of suicidal. They didn't
know they were going to win.
So, why did they go to war? Okay, that's
the first mystery we'll solve today.
Second mystery is
Remember I said that the Shia and the
Sunni
um have a major sectarian divide. The
Shia believe that only the descendants
of of Muhammad's grandson Ali can be the
caliph, the leader of the Muslim people.
The Sunnis don't. So, why didn't
Muhammad just name a successor and avoid
civil wars that would erupt after his
death? The third question
uh is why was Al Aqsa built on the site
of the Temple Mount? And this is still a
a problem today because a lot of
conflict uh
in the Middle East is driven by this
problem where the Jews want to rebuild
the temple,
uh but to do so, they would have to
destroy the Al Aqsa mosque, which is the
third holiest site in the Islamic world.
So, this is a very important question
that is still relevant to us today. So,
we will also look at these three
mysteries. And again, no one knows the
answers to any of these three questions,
and no one will ever know because so
much of the historical record has been
lost to us.
But, I will try to provide you with an
explanation.
Okay? Given uh my understanding of the
Islamic world, which by the way is
extremely limited, okay? So, uh please
ask questions. Please challenge me.
Uh I'm looking at you, Doug. Okay? All
right.
All right.
Okay. So, today's topic is Islamic
Golden Age. So, let's just have a quick
look at the Golden Age. Um, at the
height of
uh Islamic influence, there were a few
centers of incredible cultural um
creativity. Uh one such site is Bukhara,
Uzbekistan. It's still there, guys. You
you can get on a plane like Doug did and
visit it. It is an incredible city. I
say that without actually having visited
it, but I I've heard terrific terrific
things from uh Doug. And you can go
online as well and and look at videos.
But, it is an incredible city. And it
shows you the immense creativity the
artistic creativity of the Islamic
Golden Age.
But, the main
cultural center of Islamic Golden Age is
Baghdad.
Okay? It's not so beautiful now, but
back then it was really the center of
the world. Um, it's a round city
and it's a new city.
Um, this is a
um top topographical map of the city. As
you can see, it's surrounded by the
Tigris and Euphrates, and it is a round
city.
Okay? One of the few round cities of
that time.
Um
Baghdad was the capital of the Abbasid
Caliphate, which started the Islamic
Golden Age. Uh the Abbasid Caliphate is
the successor to the Umayyad
um em- empire, okay? And this is where
the Abbasid Caliphate was.
And this is uh what it what Muslims
consider the height of their
civilization.
Um, the thing that's really important
for us to understand about the Abbasid
uh empire is that not only were they
influential in the Muslim world, but
they eventually but they eventually
would come to create the world that we
live in today.
Okay? So, when you think of
globalization, we think of this as a
recent phenomenon.
But, look at the trade route that the
Abbasid Caliphate would create over its
three to 400 year history. It connects
the entire world.
Okay?
Um, as I mentioned last semester, global
globalization has always existed to a
certain extent in world history.
But, the Abbasids, the Muslim religion
would would take these existing networks
and make them rich a lot richer, a lot
more dense, and a lot faster.
Okay? So,
um you may not know this, but the
Abbasids traded heavily
with the Tang
and the Song dynasties. In fact, it is
the Abbasids who would initiate
something called the Maritime Silk Road.
The overland Silk Road has existed for a
long time, but it is the Abbasids who
who will eventually create the Maritime
Silk Road and will bring China
into the world to a greater extent than
ever before.
Okay?
So,
um this is just a trade.
Um
the main center for cultural production
uh in the Muslim world is something
called the House of Wisdom.
And it's modeled um
it it's model is the Library of
Alexandria, okay? We remember last
semester we discussed the Library of of
Alexandria in Egypt. And its mission was
to be the first university to take
all Hellenistic knowledge and culture
and systematize it for
um
dissemination.
Okay?
And the House of Wisdom
uh was doing the same thing where it
would take all knowledge
and culture within the Islamic world and
outside the Islamic world and
systematize and standardize standardize
it for mass dissemination, okay?
So,
um the things that they were doing were
they were they were taking Hindu num-
numerals, okay? So, 0 1 2 3. We still
use them today. They took them from
India, and again, they standardized it
and disseminated this knowledge.
They took works from Aristotle and
Plato, translated into Arabic and
Persian, and then disseminated it.
Um
they the main contribution of Islamic
Golden Age to world culture is in
actually mathematics.
Okay? So, they took all the math
um in the Greek world and in the Persian
world and in in the Hindu world, and
then they would systematize it and then
build on top of it.
Okay?
Um
This is a rendition of the House of
Wisdom. This is where the three major
creative civilizations would meet and
exchange ideas, right? The Greeks, the
Jews, and the Persians.
They would also take ideas from the
Indian tradition and the Chinese
tradition as well.
Um
the major literature or literary work
that we still have today from the
Islamic Golden Age is the Arabian
Nights, okay? Um, scholars have looked
at this very closely, and
most scholars believe that the story is
actually from India.
Also, what's important for us to
understand is that
at that at the time this was translated,
it was actually not that popular within
the Muslim world. Poetry, philosophy,
mathematics, science were considered the
high arts. This was considered low art.
Uh what we have today is that the
Europeans would discover this
centuries after the Islamic Golden Age,
and they fell in love with these
stories, and that's why we still have
them today. Um and Disney movies are
based on
on this as well.
Okay, so let's look at the some of the
major thinkers
uh and philosophers of the Islamic
Golden Age.
So, at this time in world history, we
don't differentiate between
philosophers, poets,
uh scientists, mathematicians, okay?
All intellectuals
engaged in all these different fields,
okay? So, the one most famous is
Rumi, who is Persian,
a poet, a mystic, a philosopher.
Um, Ibn Sina
is probably the most famous intellectual
of the Islamic Golden Age.
Um, his books, his works were admired in
Europe. Okay? So, the Islamic the
Islamic philosophy
um was being exported to Europe where it
where it would have a major influence
on many of Europe's major thinkers. You
may have heard of a man named Leonardo
Fibonacci. You should have heard of him
in math class. Well, well, at this
particular time in history, he was going
to Baghdad to study from the leading
mathematicians of this time and taking
their ideas and um importing
them all back to Europe.
Okay? So, this is Ibn Sina. Uh and the
Latin name is Avicenna.
Um, Ibn Rushd Averroes,
is also um a major intellectual at this
time.
Just to show you how influential these
two were in Europe, let's look at
Dante's Divine Comedy. So, Dante is in
uh hell, and there in limbo, he's
meeting the most influential,
the greatest philosophers in human
history who have influenced European
civilization. Obviously, he's he's going
to name Socrates and Plato, okay? But
guess what? He also names
Averroes and Avicenna, okay?
So, Dante is acknowledging
the
debt Europeans have to Islam. This is
important for us because
um the Muslim
intellectual influence on Europe has
been whitewashed from history. This is
something you do not learn in in school
usually. But without Islam, you can make
the argument that Europe could not have
modernized, okay? And later on, I'll
explain why that's the case.
Um Omar Khayyam is also another famous
um
intellectual, poet, philosopher.
Um this is This man,
Musa al-Khwarizmi,
is considered the father of modern
algebra.
His Latin name is al-Khwarizmi, okay?
And if this sounds familiar, it's
because his name will give us the modern
English word algorithm. Both algebra and
algorithm were originally Arabic words.
All right, so most of the math you're
studying in school actually originated
during the Islamic Golden Age.
Um this name is uh Alhazen, and he
invented physics, basically optics.
Um again, extremely influential. And
again, these ideas will be um imported
back to Europe, and they will become the
basis of the Renaissance, okay?
Um al-Zahrawi
is the father of surgery.
At this time in world history, uh the
very best hospitals are in the Islamic
world, by far. Um this is the first
um 24-hour hospital in Baghdad. What's
also amazing about these hospitals is
that if you are poor and could not pay,
you could receive medical treatment for
free. That was just part of the faith.
All poor were treated with great charity
and kindness um during the Islamic
Golden Age.
Uh this is al-Qarawiyyin.
Again, guys, I I'm I don't speak Arabic.
I'm probably
butchering the the name, but it was
founded in 859 in Fez, Morocco. This is
important because this this is actually
the first degree-granting university in
the whole world, and it's still there,
guys, okay? This is the oldest
university in the world. What's also
amazing is it was founded by a woman
who inherited a uh fortune from her
father, and she spent all her money
on building this university.
All right?
Brief interruption. If you ever get a
chance to go to Fez, um it is the most
amazing city in the
Morocco is an amazing country as well.
Okay. So, um 1258, the Islamic Golden
Age
officially came to an end, or or that's
what scholars believe. And the reason
why is in 1258, the Mongols will sack
Baghdad, and they will burn
all the books, okay? Or or that's what
the legend tells us.
Baghdad had a thriving bookstore
culture, and this was this was a unique
in the world. Um intellectuals, or the
elite, um they spent a lot of their
resources on buying books.
And
they um imported paper from China. They
they learned how to make paper from
China. So, books were extremely popular
within the uh within Baghdad, okay?
Especially among the elite.
Um as well, because of the Quran,
it was necessary for the elite to be
literate. It was demanded of you to be
um literate, and the Quran will also
standardize Arabic uh and make it the
official language of the entire
uh Muslim world, okay?
But
just because the Islamic Golden Age
ended does not mean that creativity
stopped in the Muslim world. This is Ibn
Khaldun, and he's considered the father
of social science,
okay? Economics,
um
philosophy of history,
politics. This man um invented a lot of
these disciplines.
He's most famous for his idea of
asabiyyah, which just means social
cohesion.
So, he was actually the first
um to systematically think about grand
history.
Why do civilizations Why do
civilizations rise, and why do they
decline?
And his conclusion is that the
borderlands are able to conquer empires
because
uh the borderlands, the people there,
have asabiyyah, which just means that
they are more egalitarian, more free,
more
cohesive as a culture. Whereas the
empire, because it's so big, it loses a
lot of cohesion.
Okay?
Um and again,
uh Ibn Khaldun is a major inspiration
for the history that I try as well.
From 1300 to 1700, the world will be
dominated by three major empires: the
Ottomans, the Safavids in Iran, and the
Mughals in uh India. They They are
collectively known as the
uh gunpowder empires.
So, what's amazing is since um its
inception about 622
up until the 1700,
the
Islamic religion dominated the world.
And so, the question for us is
why was that the case? How did Islam
overtake Europe and overtake
Christianity? Okay? That is a mystery
and question for us today
that we will look at.
Okay. So, let's go back to the three
mysteries that I introduced
um
earlier.
Why do we have no written records? Even
though we know that the people within
the movement, Jews and Christians,
knew how to read and write, okay? That's
the first question. Second question is
why didn't Muhammad name a successor?
The third question is
why was the al-Aqsa
uh mosque built on top of the Temple
Mount, okay?
So,
um this this is a paradox because Jews
were an extremely important part of that
early movement,
right? So, why why you why would you
offend the Jews like this?
All right?
Okay.
To understand what happened, okay? Let's
go back in time.
And we know that in 622, Muhammad goes
to Medina, and that's what starts the
um Islamic movement.
But let's just go over to Jerusalem
and figure out what's happening there.
And once we do that,
then we're able to figure out what's
going on in that world. It turns out in
622,
there's a major war going on between the
two major powers at this time, the
Persians and the Byzantines. And it is a
deadly war that is engulfing the entire
Middle East.
Okay? So, this is from Wikipedia, all
right? Now, guys, um
never trust Wikipedia as a historical
source,
but it's useful for us to understand
what contemporary historians think,
okay? So, this this is from Wikipedia.
The Jews have aligned themselves with
the Persians. Why? Because, first of
all, the Romans controlled Jerusalem,
and in the year 70, the Romans burned
down their temple,
and in the year 135, the Romans expel
the Jews from Jerusalem, their holy
city. So, ever since then, the Jews
obviously, they want revenge, but they
also want to return to their holy city
and rebuild the um temple. And with the
Persians, they saw this as an
opportunity because historically, the
Persians and the Jews have gotten along
very well, okay? So,
the Jews helped the Persians
take Jerusalem and and push out the
Byzantines.
But when that happens,
the Christians in Jerusalem, they
revolt,
and they force out the Jews, and then
the Byzantines, under their emperor
Heraclius, they return to Jerusalem in
the First Crusade, okay? This is the
beginning of the idea of Crusade, and
they retake the city, and then what they
do is
they expel the Jews from Jerusalem,
obviously, but then
they start to
kill a lot of Jews,
okay? And they force these Jews outside
of Jerusalem.
So, now
these Jews have nowhere to go.
But, there's something called the
constitution constitution of Medina in
Arabia,
right? There is a prophet, Muhammad, who
is promising religious tolerance for
all. All can practice their faith in
peace.
Right? So, it makes sense for a lot of
these Jews, not all of them, but a lot
of them to join this early movement.
What's important for us to understand is
that at this point, Miss Islam Muslim is
not a distinct religion.
Okay? All these people are called
believers because Muhammad sees himself
as the final messenger of God.
Okay?
Abraham was the first, then you had
Moses, then you had Jesus, and now
Muhammad is the very last. So, all these
three different traditions, the
Christian tradition, the Jewish
tradition, and Islamic tradition, in the
beginning were all just one religion,
one idea, which is to bring God to Earth
and make everyone understand that God is
the true God, okay? To create monotheism
on Earth.
That's the origin of this new religion
of Islam.
Okay? And this is the constitution
constitution of Medina, which is in the
Quran, and which we know to be
historically true. Maybe not not the
wording, okay? But, we know that this
existed.
And these people
were called believers.
And also, this would also include uh
people who believe in Zoroastrianism,
okay? Because Zoroastrianism was also um
a monotheistic religion. So, it was So,
the constitution of Medina was an
attempt to unite all monotheistic
religions into one single tradition that
fought for God.
Okay?
Also, what's really important for us to
understand is
um not only is there all this
persecution going on against Jews and
against Christians and against
Zoroastrians, okay? But, also this is a
apocalyptic state age,
where all three traditions believe this
was literally the end of the world.
If you were Jewish, you believe in a
final battle called Armageddon between
the Messiah, who would lead you, and
against two enemies called Gog and
Magog.
Okay? Guess what?
The Persians and the Romans were
fighting each other. So, you could
easily interpret this to mean the
Persians and the Romans were the Gog and
Magog enemy.
In new tradition, this should be the
final battle. This is when Jerusalem is
most threatened. Well, the Romans, the
Byzantines, just took your city and
massacred your people. So, in the Jewish
tradition, this is the end of days. This
is the final battle.
And the And the Messiah would emerge and
lead you to final victory. That person,
a lot of Jews could interpret to be
Muhammad, okay? So, for the Jews, this
is the end of days. But, for Christians,
okay? They also believe this is the end
of days because
um there will be a final battle between
the Antichrist
and the Messiah, okay? The Antichrist is
obviously Heracles, who is the emperor
of the Byzantines, who've been
persecuting
uh Rome Christians for a long time.
Remember, uh the official religion of
the Byzantines is the Holy Trinity. But,
most Christians didn't believe in the
Holy Trinity, and they were persecuted
for
uh their refusal to believe in the in
the Holy Trinity, okay? So, for
Christians, this is also the final
battle. Zoroastrians believe in a final
battle between good and evil, okay? So,
this is an apocalyptic age where
everyone believes this is it, the final
battle. Muhammad is saying to everyone,
"Guys, we're all one people. You You
unite like God, and we are here to
fight for him, okay?" And this is very
appealing
for people.
So, the best evidence for my argument is
actually the Quran, okay? So, again, we
don't have any written records of
Muhammad, but what we do believe is the
Quran um it is a collection of many of
Muhammad's
original sayings that have been redacted
over time.
Okay? So, let's look at some at passages
from the Quran to better understand how
Muhammad was thinking and what he was
preaching to the Christians, the Jews,
and the Zoroastrians.
All right.
All people of the book. By this, he
means both the Christians and the Jews,
okay?
"Why do you argue about Abraham when the
Torah and the Gospel were not revealed
until after him? Will you not reason?"
Okay? So, he's saying, "Why are we
arguing about scripture? Why are we
arguing about about belief? We all
acknowledge that Abraham is our
forefather, okay? And Abraham came
before the Bible. It came before the Old
Testament and the New Testament. So,
what's the argument?
Here you are. You argue about things you
know, but why do you argue about things
you do not know? Allah knows, and you do
not know. Abraham was neither a Jew nor
a nor a Christian, but he was a
monotheist, a Muslim,
okay? So, this is what Muhammad is
saying. A Muslim is someone who believes
in God as the only true God, and that
includes Jews and Christians.
And he was not of the polytheists, okay?
Let's also
look at Muhammad responding to the
Christian tradition. Okay, remember, in
the Christian tradition, a lot of
conflict arises from a debate over the
nature of Jesus and his relationship
with God.
Okay? And what Muhammad is saying is,
"Guys, the idea of Jesus makes no sense.
Jesus cannot be God. Jesus at best can
only be a messenger of God, just like
me.
And the idea that Jesus is is God makes
no sense. Jesus was a human, just like
me. God is God. He would He would not
represent himself through a human, okay?
And this this And so, let's let's look
at what he says.
"They disbelieve those who say Allah is
the Messiah, the son of Mary." But, the
Messiah himself said, "Messiah is Jesus,
right?
O children of Israel, worship Allah, my
Lord and your Lord." He's making a clear
distinction. God is my God. I'm not God.
I'm not his son. He is God.
"Whoever associates others with Allah,
Allah has forbidden him paradise, and
his dwelling is the fire. The wrongdoers
have no saviors."
All right? If you believe that Jesus is
God, you are committing heresy against
the true God. There can only be one God.
There can't be two gods together.
"They disbelieve those who say Allah is
the third of three, but there is no
deity except the one God. If they do not
refrain from what they say, a painful
torment will befall those among them who
disbelieve." So, what he's saying, this
is very important, is that Muhammad is
saying the Holy Trinity, the idea, is
just nonsense.
"They disbelieve those who say Allah is
the third of three. Allah cannot be a a
fraction of anything. He is the one and
only."
Okay? Now,
in our time, when we hear this, we don't
really have emotional reaction, but
place yourself back in their time, the
year 622.
Most Christians are being persecuted for
refusing to accept the Holy Trinity as
scripture because it makes no sense. We
discussed this in class,
okay? And now, but if you say it makes
no sense, you could be killed,
okay? You'll be persecuted for sure.
And no And now, Muhammad is saying, "You
guys were right all along.
You should believe in yourself all
along. You were right all along, okay?"
So, let's use an analogy.
Let's just say, for example, that the
world government, okay, we have a world
government, and for whatever reason, the
world government tells us the sky is
red.
And you're like, "Wait a minute. I know
blue, and I know red, and the sky is
blue."
But, if you were say
the sky
is blue, you will be put in jail. You
are not allowed to say the sky is blue.
And then, you have people, teachers like
me, telling you, "The reason why you
believe the sky is
uh blue and not red is your eyes lie to
you.
You cannot trust yourself.
You Your eyes are defective. That's the
problem with human beings. We can't
trust what we see."
Okay?
And you have to go through life
believing the sky is red, even though
you know in your heart it's blue. But,
then one day, someone, like a teacher,
says to you in class, "Actually, guys,
we've been lying to you all along. The
sky is blue."
Imagine your sense of relief
and empowerment and liberation when
someone of authority actually tells you
what you've always believed. Okay?
That's what Muhammad is doing. Muhammad
is confirming to everyone that what they
believed, what they knew about God, was
right all along.
Okay.
So, Muhammad's final message to the
people is
God is God and only God, and he is
everywhere, and you can see him. You can
touch him because he's everywhere. And
as such, you can feel him and he can be
inside of you.
Okay?
And so this idea will occupy most of the
Quran. Okay, and this is what he says,
"With him are the keys of the unseen.
None knows them except he, and he knows
everything on land and in the sea. Not a
leaf falls but he knows it."
And there's not a single grain in the
darkness of earth, nor is there anything
wet or dry, but is in the clear record.
All right? God is everywhere. You can
see and touch him in everything.
Okay? And so, in other words, what's
happening is that Islam is really
the first monotheistic religion in the
modern sense.
Okay?
When you think of monotheism, we
actually think of the Islamic version of
monotheism.
All right. So, what is the power of
Islam? And I want you guys to remember
this.
Islam is the power and beauty comes from
how Islam is able to unite two major
intellectual traditions in the world.
The first is paganism, right? Remember
the Vikings. The Vikings told stories.
They acted out rituals. And therefore,
there was an intimacy, concreteness, and
interconnectedness to paganism
that made us feel
happy and good.
Okay? It made us understand the world.
It made us feel as though we could
influence the world. That's the power of
paganism. But Islam is doing the same
thing by making God concrete. Okay? You
can feel God. God is everywhere. He
knows everything.
But what Islam is also doing is
he's taking the simplicity, clarity, and
absoluteness of monotheism.
Okay?
Monotheism is nice because with
monotheism, everything becomes clear to
you.
Right? Okay, there's one God. Therefore,
I just have to follow him. I just have
to believe in him.
There's like a million gods in paganism.
And so it's unclear what you should do
or how you should relate to this million
gods. But here in monotheism, the
relationship between God and you is
very, very clear.
Okay? So, in other words,
Islam is a major intellectual revolution
in human history. And we have forgotten
this because Islam, the idea,
has embedded itself into modernity
itself.
Okay? Does that make sense?
All right. So,
um what I will show you the next
over the course of this master is that
Islam really is the portal of modernity.
When we say that modernity began in
Europe,
uh we forget that Islam really built the
basis
for modernity.
Okay?
All right. So, fulfillment of the law
and prophets. It's completing the story
in the Bible.
It's bringing God to the people. You can
now touch God. You can now know God.
That's the beginning of the idea of
Protestantism,
okay?
And create heaven on earth.
And this is idea of science. Why do we
use science to make the world better?
Because God wants us to make the world
better.
All right?
So, a lot of the ideas
that will underpin modernity, that God
can be in us and that God expects
expects us to make the world better,
it's already there in the beginnings of
Islam. And that's why
we will have this Islamic golden age
because they are propelled
by their devoutness to the one true God.
Okay.
Is this clear to you guys? Any questions
so far?
Any questions so far?
All right. So, let me very really
quickly answer the three mysteries.
Okay, the first the first problem is why
were there no written records?
Um the answer is, first of all, Islam
marks a revolution.
Okay? It is overturning the social
order.
The problem though is that eventually
Islam will become the social order.
So, you obviously don't want to paint
Muhammad as a revolutionary.
Okay?
That's the first problem. Muhammad
um represented a revolution
against the social order.
All right, that's the first thing.
Second thing is that
we know that his early followers, the
companions, were all wiped out. They're
all dead. They all died.
The official history says that they were
they died in military conflicts. But
here's the amazing thing about early
Islam history. We don't have that much
evidence of military conflict between
the Arabs and the Persians and the
Byzantines. We don't. There's maybe one
city, Caesarea, where there was a there
was a siege.
But up but we think that a lot of the
conquests happened
um organically or maybe um
their enemies surrendered to them rather
than than fight them, okay? And that's
why that's why I would say it's a
revolution. It's not a a con It's not a
con con It's not a conquest. It's a
revolution where ordinary people
um were so disgusted with the current
leadership that they opted for
um a new a new belief system. Okay?
The problem though is that once you
amass power
and it's a coalition, the question then
is who's now in charge?
So, for
the next 50 100 years, there'll be a
series of civil war to to to de to to to
determine who will be in charge, okay?
Those early companions were probably
purged. The word we use is purge.
They're wiped out, including the Jews
and the Christians. We know for a fact
that
in the early days of Islam, Jews and
Christians were part of the hierarchy.
Um there's a man named St. John of
Damascus
who who was very famous and he was a uh
little official in the Umayyad
Caliphate.
Okay, we we know that as a fact. But
eventually they were purged from the
system. And if they're purged, what
happens is they they're also purged
history.
Okay?
Because if these are the companions of
Muhammad, Christians and Jews, then
they're legitimate. They're more
legitimate than you are. So, therefore
they have to purge that history.
Okay?
But knowing that, and the third thing is
that there will be a series of
continuous civil wars
uh uh among the Arabs in order to to to
determine who will be the Caliph. And
obviously they want to disguise this
history. They want they want to disguise
this history of civil conflict, okay?
So, the first 100 years, it was
revolutionary, but it was also very
tumultuous and bloody. And that's why
they had to disguise the first 100 years
of um Islamic history, all right? Does
that make sense to you guys?
And again, this is my explanation. I
could be wrong.
All right? There There There There could
be other explanations, yeah? Just to
throw in another idea, and
I think what you said
doesn't contradict either. Right.
One thing that's hard for us to to
imagine is that
that our culture would actually record
its history like a historiography. It
seems to us as a given, right?
Yep. You know, like Chinese culture
official historians going back for
200 years and so on, right? Um the
Greeks had their ancient historians. The
Romans had their ancient historians. But
not every culture has its historians. Uh
the Persians didn't write history.
Right. Um the Indians didn't write
history. And and I'm guessing the
um the Arabs didn't have a tradition of
writing down their history either,
right? And so that this would actually
be
recorded in the sense that we are
familiar with. Right. Probably wasn't
the case at all. That is a great point.
Th- Th- Thank you, Doug. So, so the So,
Doug's point is that
um
the idea of history comes to us from the
Greeks and the Romans who wrote
everything down, okay? But as Doug says,
there are many cultures who do not
believe or or do not They don't have
have institutions to write down history.
We should have taken for granted today,
but back then
it was actually a pretty rare thing to
actually want to write down your
history, okay? So, the And the good a
good reason why is that if you write
down the history,
you're also constrained by the history.
Right? And And And that's why a lot of
empires chose not write down their
history, okay? So So So, thank you.
Yeah.
All right.
Why didn't Muhammad name successor?
Again,
this is my theory. But
if it's the end of days,
if it's the end of the world, you don't
need to name a successor because God's
coming, right? What's the point? In
fact, if you name successor, then you
are admitting defeat, right?
What Muhammad is saying to everyone is
that every of your traditions, Jewish,
Christian, Zoroastrian, are right. It's
the end of days. God is coming. There
will be peace on the world. Therefore,
we will no longer need leaders. You
won't need Muhammad. I'm the last
prophet, man.
Okay? So, that's
that's why I think I That's why I think
he didn't name a
but there could be other explanations,
okay?
Do Do you Do you have another
explanation? Okay. Now, third is
why did they build the Al-Aqsa mosque
on a second temp- on on the Temple
Mount? And this explanation is going to
uh be very controversial, okay?
So, did Jews support the Persians in the
war against
the Byzantines on the condition that the
Persians would allow them to return to
Jerusalem, but also on the condition
that that the Jews would be allowed to
rebuild their temple.
Which is exactly what Cyrus the Great
did, right? Cyrus the Great is is called
the Messiah in the Bible. He's He's the
only foreign leader called the Messiah
in the Bible because Cyrus the Great
allowed them to rebuild the temple.
Okay? So, what I'm saying is this,
Al-Aqsa mosque
was originally the third temple.
It It is what the Arabs promised the
Jews
for the support.
But,
over time, as these purchases happened,
as civil conflicts happened, then the
Arabs needed to sort of consolidate
their authority. So, they turned the
third temple into the Al-Aqsa mosque.
Okay, that's what I think happened. If
you go into the I don't have time to go
into the very detailed history
of how the Al-Aqsa mosque was built, but
it was a process that took about 200
years.
It's very possible during during these
200 years intentions changed.
Okay? So, again, I I know this is an
extremely controversial statement, but I
think that's what happened. Originally,
it was meant to be the third temple.
But then, over time, the Arab leaders
changed their minds and and thought to
themselves that if we do this, then we
make
um the Jews into a very powerful
political entity within the Muslim
world.
Okay? The
Does that make sense to you guys?
All right?
Okay. Again, like
these are my explanations.
Uh
it's my interpretation. This is not
historical fact, okay?
All right.
Now Now that we've done the three
mysteries, let's go back to the three
original questions.
First question is why did Islam enter
its golden age and Christian Europe
enter its dark age? Second question is,
why did Islam enter its golden age? And
third question is, how did Christian
Europe overtake the Muslim world? Okay,
to answer these three questions,
all we have to do is compare and
contrast these three major religions
together.
Judaism, Christianity, and Islam.
All right?
There are
both strengths and weaknesses to all
religions.
So, let's very quickly compare and
contrast these three major religions to
see why they thrive in a certain
historical context.
So, Judaism.
The Bible uh it's a wonderful piece of
literature. It has a very rich history
going back
thousands of years, right?
So, the Jews were the first to have a
complete history of themselves.
There are beautiful stories in the Bible
that still inspire today. The stories of
Adam and Eve, the stories of the
patriarchs, the story of Moses. They
still inspire us today, and they inspire
us to create great literature.
And then you have a literary culture.
So, um
the Jews were expected to be people of
the book. They were expected to be
literate in order to practice their
religion.
Okay? And this help helps helps us
understand uh why Jews are so dominant
in uh academia, universities,
in the media, and in culture, and in the
legal profession, okay? Because these
are people of the book. They have a
tremendous respect for learning and for
literacy, okay?
That said, there are certain problems
with the tradition. The first is
um it's contradictory.
When you read the Bible, it's always
contradicting itself. Okay?
Um it's almost schizophrenic, you you
could say.
It's very hard to pick out a
a definite message
from the Bible, and that's why the oral
tradition uh called the Torah is
actually much more important.
Okay? And so, Jews have to go um to the
synagogue uh all the time where the
rabbi will explain to them the meaning
of the Bible because like you read by
yourself, it's almost impossible to
understand, okay? Second problem is
their god Yahweh is he's very
problematic.
He's extremely problematic. As we know
from last semester when when we looked
at the Bible, he doesn't seem to know
what he's doing, and he's very very
um violent, okay? He He often commands
the Israelites to go kill all their
enemies. Okay, so he's a very
problematic god.
And the third major problem in the
tradition is
um faith versus history. If you believe
that you're the chosen people, if you
believe that Yahweh is the only true
god, then why are you being persecuted
all the time, okay? Why Why were the
Romans able to kick you out of Jerusalem
and burn down your temple, which is the
house of god? Why are you homeless? Why
do you lack a homeland, okay? And this
has been going on for 4,000 years.
And there are no easy explanation to any
of these problems. Okay? So, within the
Jewish faith, there's a lot of conflict
and debate and doubt.
So, the Christian faith was created in
many ways to try to resolve a lot of the
issues within the Jewish tradition. The
first major advantage of the Christian
faith is it's the personification and
perfection of divinity. Right? Remember
how we said that Yahweh is problematic?
Well, now we have Jesus who we can
understand. And Jesus made the ultimate
sacrifice, therefore we know him to be
the ultimate good.
Okay? Second advantage is, okay, now
that there's a
person, we can for him deliver a
consistent message of being kind, being
merciful, being loving.
Okay?
The third advantage is
the idea of progress of history.
Everything is leading to the return of
Jesus, the second coming. Okay? So, you
may suffer now, but don't worry because
Jesus is is returning.
And that will end history for us.
All right? So, these are the advantages
of Christianity.
But, when you do that, when you have
Jesus personify god, you create a lot of
issues, okay? The first issue is
it's a really confusing story.
Why would god come down to Earth,
manifest himself as a human, and then
sacrifice himself?
That's really really confusing. Like I
know there's a lot of really good
explanations as to why this is the case,
still if you're just a normal person,
you can't understand the story. It makes
no sense to you, okay?
Second is that it's counterintuitive. A
lot of the ideas in Christianity it is
counterintuitive. The Holy Trinity must
be the strangest idea in religion where
god, the Holy Spirit, and Jesus are
separate but equal.
It makes no intuitive sense to anyone.
The third is distant divinity.
Okay?
God is out there somewhere. You don't
know where. You can't talk to him. You
can't see him. You have absolutely no
idea where he is, okay? It's a very
distant divinity.
And so, these are the disadvantages of
Christianity. And so, Islam now makes
sense because it's trying to remedy and
rectify these failings of Christianity,
okay? The first is that it takes the
Jewish tradition and Christian tradition
and makes it part of itself, okay? So,
it is really the continuation
and the perfection of the
Jewish-Christian tradition.
Second is
the absoluteness of god, okay?
This is now true
monotheism where god is everywhere.
And you can
see him.
But if god is everywhere, then what's
amazing is that you can now that god can
come inside you through your faith,
through your devotion,
and through your practice.
All right? And so, what this means is
you now know how to behave in the world.
There's a clarity of purpose and action.
You know that as long as you do those
five things, those five pillars of
Islam,
your life will be good. God is in you,
and that gives you strength
and purpose and power. Okay?
And this is these these ideas is what
will start the Islamic golden age and
allow Islam to propel itself
past everyone, okay?
The problem though is
it's too simple and clear.
The advantage of being contradictory is
you allow for different belief systems,
which come into conflict with each
other.
And with this contradiction
and conflict, it allows for innovation.
That's why Catholicism eventually uh
will eventually give way to
Protestantism, okay?
Which is a reinterpretation
of the Bible.
But it's because the Bible is so
contradictory
that
this innovation is allowed happen. The
Bible was extremely clear. The Quran is
extremely clear.
But if that's the case, then you cannot
allow for a radical rejection of the
past and embrace of the future, okay?
Second problem then is it's inflexible.
It can't be as innovative as
Christianity and Judaism.
The third problem is
it Islam proports to stand outside of
history.
Okay?
Judaism is to be inside of history.
Christianity is inside of history as
well.
But Islam is eternal. When you read the
Quran, it's meant to be the eternal
words. These words are always true.
But then the problem then is how do you
go about and interpret
your actions through the lens of
history? And how do you improve your
society
based on this interpretation?
All right?
So, in the beginning, the very aspects,
the very strengths of of Islam will give
rise to a tremendous period of
creativity, but over time,
um you will have
um the these innovations will become
dogma.
And they will ossify and they will
prevent further growth in your society.
All right?
So, does that make sense to you guys?
All right. So, let me reframe what I
just said in a different way. All right?
So, let's just compare
Sorry.
Um
Let's Sorry.
So, I'm going to compare and contrast
Christianity with um Islam.
So, so and and
and and and then and then this will be a
bit more clear to you.
All right?
Okay, but are there any questions before
I continue?
Is this clear to you guys?
So, I apologize. I'm making a lot of
generalizations, but again, this is a
macro view of of history.
All right. So, let's look at let's look
at Christianity
and compare it with Islam.
All right?
So, as I have said um in previous
classes,
Christianity was developed by the Roman
Empire in order to co-opt first the Jews
and eventually um these barbarian
invaders. And therefore,
the religion is one of empire and power.
Okay?
It's really about how to control
people.
But Islam, as I just mentioned, it is a
revolutionary religion that must be open
and inclusive and tolerant in order to
to attract as many followers as
possible.
All right? Now, the main mechanism of
control
uh for an empire is the idea of
orthodoxy.
Orthodoxy just means the correct
thinking, okay? But if you orthodoxy,
then you have the idea of heresy.
Orthodoxy is with God. Heresy is against
God. If you agree that the sky is red
because I say the sky is red, then you
are orthodox. But if you insist the sky
is blue, then it is heretical, okay?
And that constrains or limits the
imagination.
All right?
And the philosopher that you base your
society on is Plato.
So, the idea of the bishop, the idea of
the pope, it's really the idea of
Plato's philosopher king.
All right? So, I'll explain uh Plato's
philosophy in a bit in in in a second,
okay? But but let's look at Islam. So,
it's a revolutionary
religion and therefore, you must
activate the energy of all your
followers. You must get them to believe
and you must get them to fight.
Therefore, it's a religion based on
intuition.
God is with you. You know God. God is
inside you, okay? And the idea of
intuition is what allows for science.
You can discover the truth by just
observing
through empirical observation, through
your own
analysis, through your own belief, okay?
And the person who argues this is, of
course, Aristotle.
So, this is the argument I'm making you
to you, okay?
A lot of scholars believe
um
the Islamic Golden Age happened because
the Islamic Golden this the Islams had
books.
They had wealth.
But the Byzantines also had access to
all these uh major thinkers, Plato and
Aristotle. They all Byzantines had a lot
of wealth.
Okay? What I'm arguing is that a culture
needs to have have a attitude, a
perspective, a world view, an
orientation.
For the Byzantines and the Europeans,
they chose Plato.
But the Muslims chose
Aristotle.
And that is the major difference.
Okay?
So, let's go over um let's summarize
Plato and Aristotle.
How were their philosophies different?
Okay.
For Plato, the true God is called the
form of the good.
The form of the good
is the beginning of everything. It is
what is immutable, that cannot be
changed. It is
uh perfect. It is eternal. Eternal means
it's always it was always there and it
will always be there.
The form of the good, this God, he
thinks and he emanates new concepts
called ideals like justice,
uh reason, beauty, power, okay? And
these ideals will manifest themselves
into perfect forms.
Okay? Like a horse, like a perfect
horse, the perfect woman, okay?
This we can say is his heaven.
We live in something called the shadow
world,
which is just an imitation
of heaven. It's a bad imitation, so
everything sucks, okay? So, for example,
uh if you fall down and you break your
leg, it hurts because we live in a
shadow world.
So, in this conception of the universe,
what we're trying to do is return
to uh the form of the good. And for
Plato, he argues that you can do this
through mathematics and geometry
because mathematics is what is most like
the form of the good. It is it is
immutable, perfect, and eternal. So, by
studying mathematics and geometry, you
are able to ascend back into the uh form
of the good. But guess what? Augustine
will take Plato and he will adapt it to
the Christian faith, right? Because how
do you leave this world? By not sinning.
By having faith.
If you do that, then you are allowed to
go to heaven.
Okay?
So, in the Platonic Augustinian
understanding, we in this world just We
all have to do is not make a mistake.
So, do nothing.
Okay? Do nothing and you'll be good.
Aristotle
has a different conception of the
universe. He believes the form of the
good is called a prime mover.
All right?
God is a prime mover. So, God is the
first thing that acts and moves things,
okay?
And when he does that, when he creates
motion,
other things start to happen as well,
okay? So, we're constantly moving about.
Where we're going is we are seeking
truth.
It's called telos. Telos means purpose.
So, each of us by our nature has a
purpose. If you're if you're a soldier,
your purpose is to be the best warrior.
If you're a mathematician, your purpose
is to be the best mathematician, okay?
And that is the idea of truth. To
fulfill your purpose. And therefore, you
must be constantly acting, okay? Now,
the the beauty of this idea of motion is
you can now study it through empirical
observation. You can observe things and
then start to understand their nature.
And this gives rise to the idea of
science.
Okay?
All right?
The Muslim world had a decidedly
Aristotelian
perspective, whereas the European world
had a Platonic perspective.
Now, the great thing about history, the
great thing about civilization is that
what will happen is the Europeans will
learn from the Muslims. They'll copy the
Muslims.
All right?
They'll bring back Aristotle.
They'll bring back science.
Uh and they'll bring back intuition.
All right?
And they will do so through three major
events. The first is the Renaissance.
Where they bring back Aristotle. The
second is the Protestant
ref- reformation. Where they will bring
back God. Remember the Catholic
religion, God is aloof. God can only be
understood through the Pope or the
priest.
Okay? But the Protestant religion is,
no, God is with us. God is in us.
Through your actions, you can
um, you can win God's favor, okay?
And the last is science, right? The the
scientific revolution.
And these are the three major events
that will give us modernity.
Okay? But, guess what?
The Europeans are just emulating
the Muslims.
But, and this is really important, they
will improve
on
the Muslims.
Okay? So, the problem with science is,
yes, in the beginning you will have this
all this tremendous discovery, but this
is innovation
will eventually lead to something called
dogma.
All right?
And so, what you need to do is create
institutions
to destroy dogma.
And that's what the Europeans will do.
Which will, and this idea
that dogma can be destroyed through
discussion and debate and analysis is
what will become the basis of the
scientific revolution. Which will create
the modern world that we live in today,
okay? So, we will go through all of
these three major uh, movements in
future classes.
But please remember
that it's the Islamic Golden Age
which will inspire the Europeans
to do all three of these things. Which
in turn will create the modern world
that we live in today.
And that's why I believe that the
Islamic Golden Age is really the idea is
really the portal to modernity
of human history. All right.
That is my argument to you.
Any questions?
Anything you are unclear about?
Was this clear?
Okay. Maybe
maybe even
I don't know if it's a question or just
just an observation to Sure.
The
Are are you able to go back a couple
slides to the Sure. to the
empire empire and power versus religion
there. Okay.
Sure, right here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. So, this is like
one thing that you got me thinking about
the theory of the years of Islam. And
so, there's kind of two movements. Like
the first one
is like with the Umayyad Caliphate,
which lasts about 100 years. Right.
Right.
And
it it was really kind of that revolution
that that you're talking about. Like
very expansive
growth, very
very quick. Um
But it was also very Arab.
Right? And it it was done by the Arab
people.
Okay? And um
what what's really interesting is like
if we look at the Abbasid Caliphate that
comes
afterwards, um
as as sister Jane said, like it moves to
Baghdad. And right now we think of
Baghdad and Iraq as as an Arab
uh, place.
But at that time it was Persian.
Okay? And um by moving there, it it
represents partly a change in culture
and moving away from uh,
from an Arab
homeland basically. And there's a whole
bunch of like there's a an amazing
cultural openness
um by moving there. There's there's
contacts like you said with um with
India, um
Central Asia. Um
or sorry, Islam
moves into Central Asia. There's more
contacts with uh with China and so on.
And there's a real cultural dynamism
uh going on there. And and Islam has to
be
very open to those cultures and be
inspired by those cultures. Uh
Um and engage with them in in in a
pretty deep way. Right? Right. So, in
some ways it's not just the
the religion that's the deciding factor
for what makes it a golden age, but but
but just being able to draw on so many
different ancient and and rich
traditions. Yeah. Um in a way that say
the Byzantines couldn't. Or uh in
Western Europe um
you know, the Catholics that couldn't
do. Right. Yeah, that's a great point.
So, um let me elaborate on on this
point. Um so, there's a literary critic,
uh Northrop Frye.
Right? Yep, Canadian, right? So So, so,
so, Northrop Frye is Canadian literary
critic, okay? And one thing that that
he's obsessed about is how literature is
developed, okay? And what he what he's
observed is there's certain moment in
history when great literature comes
about. And that the moment is when a
nation, okay, or a people or culture
becomes an empire.
Okay? And the idea here is, okay
within a nation, you have tradition. You
have cohesion. Okay? You have a certain
um
uh, literary basis, right?
And then when it becomes an empire, it's
forced to have a vista.
It's it's forced to have like a global
perspective.
And this change from a nation, a co-
coherent people into a cosmopolitan
empire
at this stage in history
um you can it's possible for them to
produce great literature, okay? And
there are many examples of this. So, the
first example, of course, is Athens.
Athens is the
um civilization par excellence.
Right? And so, when did Athens produce
all its great
like literature? Well, it was basically
the the the age of Pericles, which
lasted from like you know, 500 to about
400, okay?
Uh maybe 350, okay? But it was not that
long.
And this is important because this
period is also when Athens, which was a
you know, a very small polis, suddenly
became an empire.
And it was this transition that forced
it to look outwards, okay?
So, Athens is one example.
But then of course, you have uh, King
David
and the the Israelites.
And again, um after Blanchett collapse,
um David was able to
like create um an Israelite nation.
And then conquer a lot of this
territory, okay? So, this this people
now were a small empire. They they
weren't a great empire, they were a
small empire. Okay? And the last example
that we we have is England.
Right? Think of Shakespeare.
When was Shakespeare writing? Around
1600, okay?
And that was when England, which for the
longest time was this poor um island
island was now becoming emerging as a
global empire. And with it a
cosmopolitan
perspective.
All right? So, this is the pattern
in history.
Which picks up on on Doug's point where
um
the new um um Islamic empire, when they
shifted their capital to Baghdad, they
and they now became a global empire. And
as such, they had to absorb all these
different traditions and cultures and
become
um a multicultural universal empire,
okay?
All right?
So, Northrop Frye has made this obser-
observation.
Um it sounds convincing. I I haven't I
haven't done enough research to fully
buy into this theory, okay? But but he
has made this argument and uh he has
made these observations with these
examples.
All right? So, thanks for that.
Okay, any more questions?
Okay. So, um next class
what what we'll do is
the Middle Kingdom, China, okay? The
reason why is
um at this stage in history, China is
being brought into world history.
And the reason why is the rise of the
Mongols, okay? So, the So, next class
will be on the Middle Kingdom, China.
And after that, we will do the Mongols.
And then after that, we will return to
Europe and do uh, the Crusades.
Then we'll do the Renaissance, the
Protestant Reformation, and the
scientific revolution, okay?